Let's count down the best Snoopy
summertime moments from Season Three.
Number eight, sandy simple pleasures.
My grandpa always says,
when it comes to simple pleasures,
nothing beats a sandcastle.
Except the tide.
Number seven, settle in for a staycation.
I'm glad you decided to stay home for a change, Snoopy.
After all, there's more to life than sitting around drinking root beer.
Oui, monsieur.
Number six, beware of picnic pirates.
(Gasp)
Number five, remember to stay hydrated.
(Gulps)
Number four, Snoopy keeps his cool.
Snoopy.
I like you as much as the next person.
That's why I feel so comfortable asking you to...
please get your dog house outta my pool!
Thanks, Snoopy.
(Popping noise)
Number three, Snoopy catches a game.
All yours Snoopy.
(Shouting)
Number two, time for a bird and beagle bath.
(Sighs)
(Excited squeals)
And number one, ice cream strategies.
Now, I ask you, Charlie Brown,
is there a more delicious puzzle to solve on a hot summer's day,
than how to properly eat an ice cream cone?
For instance, there's the "Chomper".
Brain freeze!
That method is not without its risks.
Here's another, the "Side Swiper".
Rats!
Also has a downside.
What do you call that?
A complete mess.